hello everyone welcome to me catching up
on the capcom showcase uh for this
year's e3 week i wanted to say that i
decided to actually cut like the first
half of this just because i didn't have
super strong reactions to monster hunter
or somebody who's not actively playing
monster hunter i did back in the day but
it was like 10 minutes and i wasn't
super interested
i also wasn't tremendously interested in
the capcom spotlight or exo primal so i
decided to just like kind of cut uh most
of that out and go with the stuff that i
had very strong reactions to because i
feel like it made more sense to do that
so
enjoy game looks cool thank you for
watching i think it looks fun
i will try it
next we have a message about dragon's
dogma what we celebrated its 10th
anniversary excuse me
excuse me
i didn't even think they mentioned the
words
also that game's 10 years old oh my god
no no no no no what's happening what's
happening what's happening what's
happening what about dragon stogma what
about it
i'm dying hi everyone i'm hideout suno
game director at capcom just a few weeks
ago we celebrated the 10th anniversary
of dragon dogma
thanks to all of you for joining us in
this celebration you better not just cut
to me to the world of dragons
has since spread to various different
kinds of media oh my god ranging from
games such as dragons dogma and the
darkerisms
yes and then what
in the coming days we will be releasing
a video celebrating 10 years of dragon's
dog
talking about how
and what dragon's dog okay
so there's another stream you're a long
time fan or just curious about the
series okay we'll have something for you
16th at three we hope you
check it out there's no mention of
announcements again thank you all
so much
[Music]
i'm upset it's fine
and now we have a bunch of updates from
the resident evil friend i can't believe
they just did that
hello everyone i just need to recover
from that for a second i came into this
being like i'd really love to hear about
dragon's dogma too
and i and and i had zero expectation of
the words dragon dog dragons dogma even
being mentioned
and they are mentioned but it's it's
just saying
it's been 10 years
we have a 10 year anniversary stream so
it's not even enough to say
by the way
if you watch this presentation you'll
get news it could just be a stream of
like highlights of a 10-year anniversary
okay at least the conference is now
jumping into stuff that i'm a bit more
interested in
resident evil village getting dlc
hopefully okay okay okay
it's fine it's fine
the producer of resident evil village
thanks to all of our fans village has
sold over 6 million units worldwide
dlc everyone on the team is incredibly
happy to see so many people enjoy the
game
thank you for your support
the resident evil series continues to
bring fun experiences to people around
the world it's been very consistent
[Music]
enjoy this storied franchise i'm very
happy with resident evil as ever start
with this video okay
okay
oh that's rose
the baby
the mold baby
like i forgot what you look like
i can show you things even chris doesn't
know what i can do
i want to live a normal life
this has got to be a dlc right this is
in a new game
i recognize that
yeah baby
shut up
[Music]
what's going on
cool i always love that kind of stuff
[Music]
this is such a like story-heavy trailer
[Music]
[Applause]
this is very dramatic shadows of rose
cool
i'm down it's time
marking the target i actually did not
play unless facebook
it's showtime
now
what next
that's sick
what that's right you can play as lady d
that's awesome
yo
you can play the whole game at third
parson
damn that's cool
damn i am like super happy with those
updates
that's all of that as cool as book
[Applause]
and sooner than expected
so then we get our e4
which would say sorry to keep you
waiting that's okay that lets you reveal
the dlc for resident evil village we
promised last i don't know what it is
this gamepl includes three major
features
first the third person mode
many people asked for this and we were
able to add it into the game now you'll
be able to see ethan as he desperately
fights to play through
like
as well as additional playable
characters such as chris redfield and
heisenberg of course lady dimitresk will
be there too
we've really fueled this mode up
very cool enjoy looking down on your
foes from over nine feet above as long
as you some phones slashes like what's
on mobile
the third edition is one you've surely
been waiting for an additional
shadows of rose today let me introduce
just a bit of this story
rose the beloved daughter of the main
protagonist ethan is now a grown-up main
character in this new story mode very
cool in this sequel to the main story of
village you can experience rose's
struggles with the terrifying power she
was born with to break free of the curse
of her powers she enters the
consciousness of the mega my seat
there she meets a girl who looks just
like her
i'm into it mysterious realm of
consciousness time and space is warped
beyond recognition
who calls himself michael who might be
of assistance with removing her powers
shadows of rose is set completely in a
third-person perspective in the realm of
consciousness you won't only face
creatures but the world itself seems to
be attacking you oh i'm super excited
the world itself being your greatest
enemy i can't wait to play it
how will rose find freedom from her
mysterious powers
the dlc for resident evil village
winters expansion includes all three of
these majors it's coming out in winter
necessarily in addition resident evil
village gold edition a bundle of
winter's expansion with the face game
will be released simultaneously cool the
release date is probably october 28th
that's awesome i can't wait
yeah resident evil reverse will also
begin service on the same date october
28 2022 we hope that you are looking
forward to it hell yeah dude
okay now we probably got some four
unless they just don't show it like that
i did much like much like as already
announced we are working on making the
main story of village available on mac
so that even more people can enjoy
resident evil
doesn't pertain to me but i appreciate
in addition the main story of village is
planned to be playable on playstation
vr2 the whole thing we're definitely
going to do
the ultimate immersive experience worthy
of nextgen in resident evil village
so look forward to future announcements
yes dude
up next a game that was announced
just a few days ago
let's go let's go
they keep doing these early releases
3 24 20 23 makes sense resident evil 4
baby
you want to see how it looks i want to
know what they're changing
[Music]
very exciting
[Music]
thunder wonder roost
it's been just a great week for
horror game fans which i am a big one
we really living out here
is this the same footage
that was at the playstation probably the
wrong spot to vacation eh
you will receive our most sacred body
it begins
now
i don't think this is the same thing
surely i hadn't seen that before that
was way too cool
i hope they give us more of a deep dive
if i could just forget what happened
that night
the pain
even for a second
this time
it can be different
you're looking pretty cute it has to
let's go
oh worth noting it's not on ps4 hi
everyone i'm yasujiro
director of resident evil 4
and i'm yoshiaki hirabayashi producer of
resident evil 4.
this title is a reimagining of resident
evil 4. very curious about that original
2005 release
similar to other titles in the series we
are carefully preserving what makes the
original title special while updating it
with modern flourishes for everyone to
enjoy when it launches in 2017
we'll reintroduce a bit of the game's
story yeah are they going to change
anything
resident evil 4 is set six years after
the events in raccoon city depicted in
resident evil 2 and resident evil 3. the
main character of the game leon s
kennedy survived the raccoon city
incident and was assigned as an agent
directly under the president of the
united states leon is dispatched to a
quiet village in europe as part of a
mission to rescue the kidnapped daughter
of the president
you might notice leon is much more
mature and fearless due to his past
experiences
the main enemies of this game wait for
him
the experience of being attacked by
hordes of crazed gennado is truly an
iconic moment
in order to truly bring out the concept
of terror of people controlled by
madness the gonado have been completely
redesigned
let's take a closer look
at the game itself i would love to good
so thank you
the over-the-shoulder camera returns of
course
leon arrives at a dense and dangerous
forest
we want to nail the feeling of
loneliness and fear of not knowing what
lies ahead even more so than the
original that's interesting well you'll
be fine of course graphics is so much
worse there will also be thrilling
battles not worse objectively better
people that played the recent resident
evil 2 and resident evil 3 should find
this familiar
this is the
the first shackle look forward to future
announcements
we'll have more information
resident evil 4 is being developed for
playstation 5 xbox series x series s and
pc
the release date will be march 24th
2023. i go wait
please go huh we are aiming to create a
resident evil 4 that everyone can enjoy
so please look forward to it i am thank
you thank you
still very curious about how much
they're going to change and
all that good stuff resident evil 4 has
almost been released as many times as
skyrim and i'm okay with it
what did you think about the latest
information on resident evil village and
resident evil 4. very excited about
dragon's dogma but also
currently in development
for those that can't wait for the
release check out the following games
oh
world premiere
[Music]
what is this
i mean i know what this is but it's like
a collection
[Applause]
[Music]
are you just telling me to play these
loops
that i have already
fair enough i guess
[Music]
okay all very good i actually still
haven't finished three i mean i have but
it was technically someone else's save
file so i need to go back and
do it
and i try and do that on stream
would like to do it on my own file
three titles return for the latest
generation oh is this an update
cool
resident evil 7 which brought the series
back to its survival horror thankfully
and the re-imagining of classic titles
resident evil 2
and right i
got a cinema to play resident evil 2 and
titles
we finished
as well as 3d audio for an even more
immersive experience
these titles are available for
playstation 5 and xbox series x and
series beginning today okay i guess they
want shows
playstation 4 and xbox one players can
enjoy a free digital upgrade yeah
via the digital upgrade program and
smart delivery it should always be that
way
for pc users an update patch will be
available on the same date
for newcomers and veterans of survival
horror alike we hope you enjoyed the
immersion these new versions offer thank
you
i really like it welcome
to the family
that's all for today's
thank you this made me very happy like i
don't know i'm very into this one um
just like a really deep dive at games i
really like i guess wraps up today's
show we hope you're as excited as we are
about some of our upcoming games
obviously wasn't as interested in some
of the stuff at the beginning of this
particular conference
we look forward to sharing more updates
with you i can't believe they mentioned
dragon's dogma i can't believe it